welcome today's update on covet 19 in
alberta with us today is dr deena
hinshaw chief medical officer of health
for alberta
dr hinsha will provide brief remarks and
then we will open the floor to questions
i now turn over to dr hinshaw
thank you lisa and good afternoon
everyone
due to a scheduling challenge we
unfortunately again do not have sign
language interpreters available today
i'm sorry for the disruption this causes
for deaf and hard of hearing albertans
as always a summary of my update will be
shared on my twitter account later today
and the full transcript of my remarks
will be posted to alberta.ca tomorrow
morning
over the last 24 hours we have
identified 2 370 new cases of covet 19
and completed 7
338 tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases is about 34 percent
with respect to the more than 2 500
schools in the province alberta
education has confirmed that as of
february 2nd
19 have shifted to temporary at-home
learning to address operational
challenges
of these schools four have fewer than 40
students total
across the province less than one
percent of schools are currently
operating online
looking to hospitalizations there are
currently 1
584 people total with covert 19 in
hospital including 112 in the icu
sadly 15 new deaths were reported to
alberta health over the last 24 hours
my sympathies are with their loved ones
and every albertan who has lost someone
they cared about no matter the cause
today i would like to provide an update
that we are making to our quarantine
recommendations
effective immediately we are updating
our recommendation for quarantine for
asymptomatic unvaccinated household
close contacts of confirmed cases to
align with other jurisdictions in canada
starting today we recommend that these
individuals stay home for 10 days after
exposure instead of the current
recommendation of 14 days
this applies to all albertans including
those in continuing care
reducing the length of time recommended
for unvaccinated asymptomatic household
contacts of confirmed cases
to 10 days from 14 days
aligns with data showing the incubation
period for omicron is shorter than
previous variants
as new evidence emerges we will continue
to review the appropriateness of the
duration of the recommended quarantine
period
our data is indicating that we are
likely beginning to turn a corner with
this fifth wave
while this is encouraging news there are
steps we need to continue to take to
protect ourselves and each other
in particular vaccines remain critically
important
the booster dose has been shown to
strengthen protection against severe
outcomes from omicron including
hospitalization
getting fully immunized against covid19
doesn't just protect an individual it
also helps protect those around them
it helps us all by easing the strain on
hospitals and our frontline healthcare
workers
i also know that due to widespread
transmission there are questions from
albertans about whether they need to be
vaccinated against covid19 or get a
third dose if they have previously been
infected with the virus
i believe the best way to combat
hesitancy is with accurate information
and i would like to answer these
questions
there is evidence that recovery from
covid19 with earlier strains provides
some protection against future
reinfection
but we don't know how strong that
protection is or how long it lasts
the level of protection from
infection-acquired immune responses
will vary in each individual
this level depends on how mild or severe
their prior infection was the time
elapsed since they have recovered from
infection
their age and whether they have a
compromised immune system or other
medical conditions
the evidence is also clear that those
who have previously been infected
and who also have received vaccine have
a significantly stronger level of
protection than recovery from infection
alone
regardless of whether or not an albertan
has antibodies from a previous covid19
infection
getting fully vaccinated with all the
doses we are eligible for is still the
best way to make sure that we and those
around us are protected against severe
illness and outcomes such as
hospitalization due to covid19
there are also questions about how long
people should wait to get their vaccine
after recovering from covid19
there is no set waiting period in
alberta
people who have recovered from covet and
have no contraindications to the vaccine
can choose to receive it as soon as
their isolation period is over
this applies to first second and third
doses
there are advantages and disadvantages
of different timing options
receiving vaccine immediately
or waiting a few weeks or months after
recovery
if you have time if you have questions
about what time frame might be best for
you
i encourage you to speak to a health
care provider and you can also read the
available information on our website
in closing today i want to speak briefly
about the concept of moving to an
endemic approach to covet my colleagues
in other provinces which are farther
ahead in the omicron wave and where
hospitalizations are declining
have been speaking publicly about the
fact that we need to plan and move
towards a different way of managing
covet
i agree with my colleagues that this is
the direction we need to move when we
see similar trends in our acute care
system in alberta
this is a shift in thinking that can be
challenging
given that we have needed to use
extraordinary tools at our disposal over
the past several years to protect our
health system and our communities
what i want to be clear about is what
moving to endemic means
kovid will not go away
there will continue to be impacts on our
acute care systems that will rise and
fall with seasonality and new variants
that may emerge
we cannot prevent all negative outcomes
from covid and we must be ready to
respond to new information
what has been important throughout the
covid response is seeking balance
between the harms of covet and the harms
of the measures needed to prevent an
overwhelming surge of severe outcomes
i believe that after the omicron wave
has subsided the risk of our system
becoming overwhelmed will be
substantially reduced
and this will enable to shift our
response
this change will take time and we need
to continue monitoring severe impacts
and any changes to the virus
but we cannot continue to use
restrictions in the long term once the
risk of system overwhelm has passed
our acute care system is still under
strain today
we need to continue to protect it and by
extension all of us
however it is also true that in the
future we will be able to remove
restrictions and indeed we must continue
to balance our response to minimize all
harms across all areas
the pandemic has never had one single
right way to respond but what is always
true is that the actions that each of us
take every day matter to our communities
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
due to scheduling today we will need to
wrap up at about 4 p.m so we'll try to
get through as many
questions as we can
please limit yourself to one question
and one follow-up
we have one reporter here in the room so
we'll get started and then move to the
phone
hi dr hinshaw um janet french from the
cbc has the restrictions exemption
program
been achieving its objectives and if so
what objectives do you think it's
achieved
the restrictions exemption program was
put in place in september
in the midst of our fourth wave with a
dramatic surge of delta which was
causing very significant strain on our
acute care system in particular in icus
we saw that
with the implementation of the
restriction exemption program our
vaccine coverage rates went up very
significantly as there was added
incentive for people to get the
protection that vaccine offers to those
who receive it and to those around them
we also saw that in those locations that
had the rep implemented
there were reductions in
the risks of transmission because of the
fact that those who were in those
locations
were fully vaccinated or had that recent
negative test
so the restriction exemption program
has certainly had a significant
beneficial impact we know from our
current data that omicron is escaping
both previous infection protection and
vaccine protection at greater rates than
the delta
variant did but we also have seen
evidence that having two or three doses
does minimize the chance of onward
transmission in someone who has a
breakthrough infection compared to
someone who is unvaccinated so there is
still benefit in
ensuring that we are
protecting our communities through
vaccination
janet do you have a follow-up yeah just
to follow up on that i mean in your mind
would alberta continue to benefit from
having a restriction exemption program
and why or why not
the
decisions about policy including the
length of time the restriction exemption
program is in place
are decisions that are
the purview of elected officials
with respect to the
impact of vaccines again vaccines
continue to be very important they are
important at protecting the individual
who receives that vaccine as well as
those around them
and so i would continue to encourage
albertans to receive all vaccines
they're eligible for as
it's clear that with the omicron wave
the third dose is particularly important
at minimizing the risk of infection and
also the risk of severe outcomes
thank you operator could you please put
through today's first caller
thank you sarah chu city news
hello dr dina my first question is it
connects to the ones that you were just
answered but with hospitalization for
clovis doe hi burnout in the medical
system still present are you on board
with premier kenny saying that the
restrictions exemption program could be
lifted soon
i am not aware of any final decisions
around timing of
lifting of restrictions
i
want to emphasize that as you said the
acute care system is under strain and
it's critical that all of us
play a part in minimizing the spread of
kovidge to protect the system
and that includes all of the actions we
take every day and
choices around vaccine
sarah did you have a follow-up
yes i do so concerning long covet and
how many people can't work full time if
at all because of their debilitating
symptoms would you consider long covert
a disability and would the government
consider creating financial aid to help
sufferers
there is still as you know a lot of
research that we need around the effects
of what's variably called long covid
postcovid syndrome there's a few
different names we're working with
alberta health services on some
different projects to understand the
impacts
in how that plays out in the lives of
individuals who are impacted by it
those people who are suffering from
longer term impacts of kovidge can
access services through alberta health
services in terms of the health care
needs that they have
with respect to financial compensation
for those who are experiencing a medical
condition that renders them unable to
work or to participate in activities the
way they used to
that would be a question that i would
have to
take back with comms and determine
which of the
portfolios might be able to answer that
but
ultimately anyone who's experiencing a
medical condition that
means that they are not able to work
it's my understanding that there are
programs that exist to support people
who are experiencing those kinds of
conditions
thank you operator could you please put
through the next caller
thank you helen pike cbc
hi there thank you so much for speaking
my question i'm just wondering uh i know
that you spoke yesterday i believe about
rapid tests coming into the province um
do you know
uh is that the first kind of delivery
we've had in a while can you kind of
detail
you know how long we've been waiting on
these and how the flow is into the
province now
we can provide more specific details on
volumes and dates uh offline what i can
say is that because of some of the
supply chain challenges that we've
experienced with the increase in demand
globally
that the supplies that we had
anticipated that we would receive in
late december and early january many of
those shipments were delayed to late
january early february so as
you likely know in
the early to mid part of january
what we needed to do was prioritize the
available supplies to health care
settings and schools and this week we
have enough that we're able to begin
restocking pharmacies at the alberta
health services locations that are sites
for distribution of rapid tests as well
as sending additional rapid tests to
first nation communities
we will continue to make rapid tests
available
as long as that supply is
is available to us
uh helen did you have a follow-up
yeah i'm wondering if we are expecting
regular deliveries or if it's still if
we're still in this situation of um you
know kind of waiting around for sporadic
um
supply chain related delays
i think it would be best to follow up
offline just in terms of being able to
give you the exact numbers of what we
have on order the dates that we're
expecting those to arrive
we have different programs there is the
workplace regular asymptomatic screening
program and then we also have the
uh
distribution of kits to those who may
have symptoms and need it to
determine if they have covet or not and
so
there are different volumes in each of
those different programs different
timelines so we'll follow up offline and
make sure you get that information
thank you operator could you put through
the next question please
kevin nimick ctv
hi dr henshaw you said you aren't aware
of a set time to ease restrictions but
the government party has made clear the
restrictions exemption program will be
cancelled in the coming days would you
support an announcement tomorrow to
cancel the rep by the following monday
decisions around policy are
the purview of elected officials the
uh choices about timing and how that
policy is implemented
are theirs to make as they consider all
of the factors that
are part of
their considerations
i would urge all albertans because of
the strain that our healthcare system is
under to
continue
making decisions that protect the
healthcare system and protect our
communities
and then the policy decisions again are
made by those who are elected
[Music]
kevin did you have a follow-up question
yes i understand the decisions are made
by those who are elected but it's your
job to give them the advice so once
again would you support announcing
tomorrow is it a good idea in your
opinion if tomorrow the announcement
comes that the rap will be cancelled by
the following monday
i have provided my recommendations to
elected officials and the
recommendations are under cabinet
confidence they're aware of the the
recommendations that i've provided based
on current state and my perspective
and
they
have always taken my recommendations
into consideration however that's not
the only factor in the decisions that
they make
thank you operator could you put through
the next caller please
jason microsoft mcleans
uh thank you very much um
what is the difference um
of transmission risk between somebody
who is
uh unvaccinated and vaccinated
during omicron and how does that compare
to
the relative risks
with delta
so some of that
level of detail
we don't have available in terms of the
the specific
transmission risk of an individual what
we've seen is that the protection level
that two doses of vaccine offers against
infection with omicron has fallen so
depending on how long it's been since
that second dose was received at about a
six-month time frame from when that
second dose was received there's not a
lot of protection left against a person
getting infected with omicron thankfully
there is still
a level of protection against severe
outcomes so that person who has two
doses is less likely to go on and need
hospitalization or or have other severe
outcomes
however
again they they can get infected there
is a reduced chance of that person with
two doses
passing it on to others
but that protection is enhanced when you
look at three doses
that
boosts protection up to about 60 percent
level of protection against infection
with omicron and boosts the protection
against hospitalization to 95 percent
so again vaccines are still important
that third dose is particularly
important with omicron
and even the two doses help against
severe outcomes
thank you jason did you have a follow-up
question
i do
dr hinshaw
with respect to kobit
19 would you feel personally as safe
going into a restaurant that did not
check vaccine status as you would dining
at a restaurant with
that did check for vaccine status or
proof of test
personally
i
have
not
eaten in a restaurant for more than two
years
so i think it's important that everyone
assess their risk level and determine
what choices are right for them based on
the particular context their own risk
factors
and
what the kinds of
specific risks they may have in their
own life and how they wish to navigate
them
great thank you could we please operator
put through the next question
paula tran global calgary
doctors finchall thank you for taking my
question um i wanted to ask about the
restrictions exemption program again um
we've heard in the past few days that
premier wants to lift the restrictions
exemption program
um but given the amount of deaths we've
seen in the past two weeks can you
explain the reasoning
just so that we can understand
i'm afraid i'm not able to speak on
behalf of the premier
did you have a follow-up question i
do um in the past few days we've seen
some medical professionals in canada
calling on provinces to mandate a third
dose on vaccine passports are you
considering this for alberta at this
time
with omicron in particular that third
dose is very important with respect to
minimizing infection risk as well as
enhancing the protection against severe
outcomes
policy decisions around the mandates in
terms of restriction exemption program
are decisions of elected officials
thank you operator could we please put
through the next caller
rick bell calgary sun
uh good afternoon doctor i know it might
be tiresome for you to get the people
asking the same question but
this is really a pivotal question i
understand you're an advisor not a
policy maker i realize you're unelected
not elected
and i realize there's something called
cabinet confidence
um
but i think albertans would like to know
no matter where they stand on the covet
issue and the coveted question
is as a doctor do you believe that under
the current conditions that we have the
hospital numbers that you outlined the
icu numbers that you announced today
do you believe
that this is the right time from a
medical point of view
to remove the vaccine passport yes there
are other factors there are other
factors that the government has to take
into account but just on the narrow
metric of
of that you're dealing with you know the
the health situation what is your
diagnosis
i think rick that you have answered your
own question i know it sounds like a
simple yes or no answer
the reality is again that i have
provided my advice that is as you say
under cabinet confidence um i continue
to underscore that the healthcare system
is under significant strain and that the
choices that each of us make the actions
each of us take every day they matter to
our healthcare system and to everyone
around us who may need care for any
reason not just covet
then as you say the decisions
about all of the different competing
considerations are decisions that
elected officials are are empowered to
make
rick did rick did you have a follow-up
yes a quick one so as an advisor
to the government how do you feel when
in the course of about a week
we've heard that
maybe we could get rid of backseat
passports by the end of march maybe we
can get rid of all restrictions by the
end of march maybe we can get rid of the
vaccine passports at the end of february
maybe we could get uh
next week in a few days very soon
um
when you hear uh when when albert was
here all of this happened in the course
of seven days
very very different messages
how does that make you feel as a person
advising the government
because we've gone from back team
passports dawn at the end of march the
vaccine passport is gone at the end of
february the vaccine passports may be
gone on monday and this has all happened
in just a few days
there are
a lot of considerations that elected
officials have to take into account um
and so i
can't speak on their behalf
i can understand that it could be
confusing for albertans to understand if
it is still important to minimize covid
risk or not
i just want to underscore again what i
had said earlier that
it can also be confusing to hear
different provinces begin to signal
their
way forward in terms of easing measures
and
i think the important thing for
albertans to know is that our health
care system remains under significant
strain right now and that other
provinces
are ahead of us in the omicron wave and
so the the ways that they're beginning
to talk about omicron are appropriate to
their context and what we need to do is
look at our context and multiple factors
that weigh into that so i would continue
to urge albertans to
be cautious to be mindful of their
communities when they decide what
actions they're going to take
i understand there's one question left
in the queue so operator could you
please put through our final question
duncan kinney progress room
hello thank you for taking my question
close my question has to do with
you know the many failures of
you and the government of alberta to
stop the spread of kovis
and now we've got reports credible
reports that government alberta is
seriously considering
getting rid of the restriction exemption
program the maxing passport program on
monday
if that were to happen
would you resign
it's important when we look at the past
two years to consider how alberta has
experienced covid in the context of a
global pandemic
and
what i can say from my own
personal
responsibility is that i have always in
every situation done my best to provide
recommendations based on the information
i had at that time and what i believed
was in the best interest of the overall
health of albertans
we have had to focus on covid infection
in a way that we have never had to focus
on any infection before
and as a result
there have been
other health issues
that have gotten worse and some of the
restrictions that we've needed to
implement have also had harms so
certainly i have made mistakes i have
admitted to that and
have apologized and i will continue to
provide the advice that is the best i
can offer based on the information at
the time
and
ultimately the decisions that elected
officials make are their responsibility
and i cannot speak for them and i do not
direct them
thank you we are out of time so that
concludes today's availability thank you
for joining us and have a good evening